في هذه المشاهد يظهر محمد في سن المراهقه
تقريبا وهو يتصارع مع والده الصور قد تبرز
ايضا شغف محمد برياضه الكاراتيه التي اصبح
لاحقا بطلها في ايران قبل ان يتم اعدامه
اما هذه الصور فتحمل مشهدا معكوسا حبل
المشنقه اختطف الشاب ده الواحد والعشرين
عاما من ابيه الى تحت التراب ليبقى منه
اسم على شاهد وصورته بيد الاب اربعه شبان
محمد احدهم ومسؤول الرفيع سابق اعدمهم
النظام الايراني منذ اشتعلت الشوارع
بالاحتجاجات الشعبيه والد محمد بائع
مناديل يتنقل صيفا وشتاء في شوارع الكرش
باحثا عن مستر بن اخبر بي بي سي لبريطانيه
ان ابنه بريء من تهمه قتل عنصر البسيج
التي سلبت حياته سمحت المحكمه لمحمد بخمس
عشره دقيقه فقط ليدافع عن نفسه وبحسب
بيبسي شعره بالخطلان عندما اكتشف الخديعه
فالمحامي الذي عيانته المحكمه اكتفى بطلب
العفو لجات عائلته محمد الى توكيل محامي
حقوق الانسان الايراني البارز محمد حسين
اباسي الذي تجاوب الا ان المحك تجاهل طلبه
في مره وفي اخرى رفضته عاده تحرم المحكمه
اهالي المتهمين من حضور محاكمات ابنائهم
يوم صدور حكم الاعدام بحق محمد كرمي
بمحاكمه انه وصفت بالسريعه والسوريه تمكن
من الاتصال بوالده محمد بكى وهو يطلب عدم
ابلاغ امه بامر حكم الاعدام وكان خوفهم
قسم بين الخشيه من لحظه الاعدام والخوف من
ان يعتصر قلبه امه الما لكن قلبها قطر بعد
ايام من اتصال محمد الاخير
وبحسب مراقبين فالخسرات التي تلحق بارواح
المحتاجين او القتلى من عناصر الامن تبقى
ضحيه اسرار النظام على الحل الامني لاخماد
الاحتجاجات حنان المصري العربي